[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
بعد قصف عنيف ورد متاخر ايران تمهل العراق
10 ايام لنزع سلاح جماعات كرديه
الميكانيكا
وخيارات كيا امام الشتاء تضيق اما توفير
طاقه او التهجير
السعوديه تنفي بشكل قاطع التقارير عن
مناقشتها زياده انتاج النفط بمقدار النصف
مليون برميل يوميا
ولدينا ايضا
الحزب الديمقراطي يجدد دماء قياداته لكن
تبقى مشكلته الاهم فراغ عرابه التاثير
والتمويل نانسي فيلوسي
وفي المونديال منتخب ايران يخسر امام
انجلترا لكنه يسجل في مرمى نظامه
والطواحين تدور على حساب السنغال
[موسيقى]
ردا على القصف التركي والايراني الذي بتى
يعتبر شمال العراق بلا صاحب نددت الخارجيه
العراقيه بشده بالهجمات الايرانيه
والتركيه واعتبرت انها تمثل مخالفه واضحه
للمواثيق الدوليه وشددت الخارجيه على
رفضها لان يكون العراق ساحه لتصفيه
الحسابات ياتي هذا بينما بعد الكتله
الكردستانيه الحكومه العراقيه للحضور
للبرلمان غدا لاتخاد موقفا من هذه
الاعتداءات معتبره ان تشكيلها لجان تحقيق
لم يعد كافيا يبدو ان الامور قد تكون
مرشحه للتطور اكثر اذن بعد ان كشفت مصادر
عراقيه و كرديه
القدس الايرانيه الاسماعيلي هدد العراق
خلال زياره الاسبوع الماضي بعمليه عسكريه
اذا لم يتصدى لجماعات المعارضه الكرديه
هسه احنا ما نقدر نواجهم عسكريين انتقل
نستطيع توفير منظومات الدفاع الجوي لايقاف
هذه الى جامعه ايقاف ما نستطيع ايقافه
واليوم مثل الاخرى التوغل البري هذه خطر
كبير اعتقد ايران تريد ان تنحى منحها
تركيا ايضا ان تتوغل بعمق وتحدث ما يسمى
بالمناطق الامنه وغيرها من الامور وحقيقه
العراق
يجب ان يقف وقفه قويه اتجاه كل هذه الامور
مجلس النواب اليوم هو اعلى سلطه في العراق
لذلك اتخاذ قرار بمنع هذه التوغراسي وكانت
ايرانيه وتركيه مهمه جدا يعني على العراق
ان يتخذ قرار باخراج كل القوات
الاجنبيه من الاراضي العراقيه عدد التي
تملك اتفاقيه مع جانب العراق من يملك
اتفاقيه مع الحكومه العراقيه هذا امر اخر
ولكن من لا يمكن سوى كان فصائل مسلحه سواء
كانت جيوش لدول جاره يجب ان تخرج ومنع اي
انتهاك وتوغل من اي جهه في الاراضي
العراقيه من حسب وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه
نحن لا نملك اي اتفاقيه عاده او قبول من
الحكومه العراقيه عذاب قبول قوات التحالف
والجانب الامريكي
اذا من الشمالين الشرقيه والغربي تصب
ايران وتركيا غضبهما لاسباب مختلفه على
منطقه واحده كردستان العراق بالامس كانت
تركيا واليوم ايران فالحرس الثوري اعلن عن
سن هجمات جديده استهدفت مجموعات كرديه
ايرانيه في كردستان العراق قالت القوات
البريه الايرانيه ان العمليه التي تمت
بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره استهدفت
مقرات لتدريب وتنظيم تلك المجموعات في
مخيمي كان وزرغيز ومدينه
واوضحت في بيان انه تم خلال هذه الهجمات
تدمير الاهداف المقصوده والحق خسائر كبيره
بالمجموعات الكرديه في المقابل اعلنت
اجهزه مكافحه الارهاب في كردستان العراق
ان الضربات طالت اهدافا كرديه بينما كشف
المستهدفان الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني والتنظيم كومالا القومي الايراني
عن تضر في عدد من منشاتهما شمال العراق
ايران كانت اتهمت هذه المجموعات الكرديه
باثاره الاحتجاجات داخل البلاد منذ منذ
مقتل مهساميني كما وجه عدد من المسؤولين
تحذيرات بهذا الصدد للسلطات في بغداد
واربيل لكن الحسبه الديمقراطيه
الكردستانيه الايرانيه اعتبر في بيان على
تويتر ان النظام يداري بهجماته العشوائيه
عجزه عن وقف التظاهرات الجاريه في كردستان
ايران وعموما البلاد
[موسيقى]
القصف الايراني
كردستان العراق الهجوم داعيه المجتمع
الدوليه
قالت اربيل ان ما وصفتها بانتهاكات
الايرانيه المتكرره التي تمسوا سياده
العراق والاقليم غير مبرره وتشكل انتهاكا
صارخا للاعراف الدوليه وعلى قاعه حسن
الجوار لكن ايران وصلت التحدي وقالت انها
تعمل لا تستخدم الاراضي العراقيه لتهديد
امنها حسب ما قال المتحدث باسمي وزاره
الخارجيه ناصر كنعاني الابعد من ذلك ندد
المتحدث بما وصفه بعدم التزام حكومتي
بغداد واربيل بوعودهما المتكرره معتبرا ان
ايران قامت بما يتوجب عليها لضمان امن
مواطنيها وحدودها واراضيها دوليه اندعت
بحثت الامم المتحده في العراق الى وقف
الهجمات المتكرره التي تنتهي سياده بلاد
قالت ان مثل الهجوم الاخير يزيد التوترات
بل يتسبب ايضا في وقوع ماساه السفيره
الامريكيه في العراق الينا رومانوسكي
اعتبرت هي الاخرى ان الهجوم الايرانيه
يمثل انتهاكا لسياده العراق وطالبت بضروره
وقف هذه الهجمات غردت رومانوسكي عن ان
الهجمات بالصواريخ والمسيرات تعرض
المدنيين الابرياء للخطر وتدمر البنيه
التحتيه اما القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
فدانت ضربات الايرانيه عبر الحدود وصفتها
بلهجمات العشوائيه غير القانونيه التي
تعرض المدنيين للخطر وتنتهي السياده
العراقيه وتقود ان المنطقه
[موسيقى]
وبالعوده الى الطرف الاخر شريك ايران في
القصف على شمال العراق وهو تركيا فلا يبدو
ان هناك مؤشرات للتراجع في موقفها تركيا
كانت دافعت عن عملياتها العسكريه
باعتبارها ضروريه لمنع شني الهجمات ضدها
ولتامين حدودها الجنوبيه وشددت على انها
تتوافق مع القانون الدولي اردوغان من
جانبه اشار الى عدم وجود قيود على العمليه
مشيرا الى ان استمرارها وارد وربما لا
تقتصر على الغارات الجويه اذ قد تمتد لعمل
بري يشمل العراق وسوريا غير ان هذا الامر
يبقى رهنا بالحاجه
[موسيقى]
معنى من بغداد المستشار الحكومي دكتور
حسين علاوي اهلا بك معنا دكتور في العربيه
يعني برايك ماذا على العراق ان يفعل
وخياراته ليست بالكثيره والمتعدده للاسف
فيما يتعلق بتركيا وايران ولا ايضا ببعض
الجماعات الكرديه بحكم العلاقه مع كردستان
العراق خاصه مع التهديدات الاخيره باجتياح
بري وليس فقط من طرف واحد انما من الطرفين
مجتمعين تركيا وايران
يعني مساء الخير عليك استاذ محمد مساء
الخير على المشاهدين الكرام اهلا وسهلا
يعني اكيد العراق نعم امام تحدي ولكن
الفرصه التي الان امام حكومه السيد محمد
الشاعر السوداني هو ان تضع خارطه الطريق
لهذا المسار وخالد الطريق تبدا من ما اشار
اليه السيد رئيس الوزراء وحتى انه اليوم
في زيارته الى المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
يريد ان يرسل رساله ان السياسه الخارجيه
العراقيه سياسه مستقله لا تدخل في المحاور
ولا تدخل في الصراعات ولا تدخل كذلك في
المقابل في ان نكون من ارث الماضي همم
طريق همم جديد همم لمسار الحكومه الجديده
ومنهاج الوزاري الذي يركز على التنميه
والعمار والبنيه التحتيه وكذلك بالمقابل
تطوير العلاقات الخارجيه واستقرار العراق
طبعا في الاخير المسافه يعني
الطلبات همم ايران بشكل دائم ومتكرر هذا
محور بيحد ذاته يعني يا اما تكون على همم
يعني مع جميع المحاور وتلابون جميع
المحاور يمنعون جميع المحاور حيث يجب او
لا
اكيد ما يهمنا هو المواطن العراقي ما
يهمنا هو السياده الوطنيه وكيفيه تحصينها
لانه السياده الوطنيه عالت من تحدي
الارهاب الذي هو فتح مسارات وكذلك سياسات
النظام السابق التي هي هذه الازمه الممتده
لوجود المعارضه الايرانيه والمعارضه
التركيه على الشريط الحدود العراقي الذي
يمتد لاربعين سنه يعني علينا ان ندرك ان
السياق الذي اسس لهذه المشكله هي الاربعين
سنه الماضيه التي ولدت هذه وهمم استثمرت
في الوضع واستثمرت كذلك في مواجهه الحكومه
الاتحاديه للعمليات الارهابيه واجيال
الارهاب وهذا بالتالي ما جاء على المشكله
تتفاقم عالجت الحكومه في زمن حكومه السيد
همم المالكي همم مشكله همم جماعه خلق وانه
المشكله بتفاعل مع المجتمع مع الدولي ثم
انهت الموضوع بقيت لدينا مشكله كذلك كانت
بناء الثقه مع حكومه تقليم كردستان والان
الثقه متميزه بين الحكوميتين الاتحاديه
وحكومه تقليم كردستان وهذا بالتالي ما
يؤسس من قدره الان العام للقوات المسلحه
في عمليه اداره الحدود الدوليه بنظره
جديده بالتفاعل مع قياده العمليات
المشتركه مع قوات حرس الاقليم هذا الكلام
شو معناته عمليا مقابل طلب واضح بانه
هؤلاء المسلحون يجب ان يغادر ويجب ان ينزع
سلاحهم هل هناك قدره على فعل ذلك ما لم
تستطيع فعله طيله همم سنوات الماضيه
نعم ولكن نحتاج الى همم تاسيس الى هذا
المسار هذا المسار يحتاج الى حوار داخلي
اولا بين الحكومه الاتحاد والحكومه
الاقليم وبين القوه السياسيه العراقيه
للوصول الى خيار كذلك مع السيد رئيس
الوزراء وكذلك مع البرلمان من جهه ومن ثم
كذلك بالمقابل دعوه ايران وتركيا كذلك الى
مبادرات اقليميه وعمليه التسويه اقليميه
مع القوه المعارضه لها لان القوه المعارضه
لها بسبب التداخل الجغرافي استثمرت في هذا
الموضوع فبالتالي في كل مره وهذا همم تشير
اليه وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه الانتهاك في
مبادئ حسن الجوار وكذلك الاعراب والقوانين
الدوليه وهذا بالتالي انعكاسي على المواطن
خصوصا في يقدم كردستان الذي بدا يتعثر
والقرى القريبه من الحدود
الايرانيه العراقيه او التركيه العراقيه
وهذه مشكله كبيره اتوقع ذلك الان فرصه
لوضع خارطه الطريق من قبل الحكومه
العراقيه مساعده البرلمان وغدا هنالك جلسه
في البرلمان طبعا سوف يتم النقاش فيها
وكذلك بالمقابل اعطاء الجهات الاختصاصيه
والجهاز الحكومي في قدره قوات حرس الحدود
من بناء همم يعني نقاط حدوديه ترتكز تمويل
هذه المسارات بالتكنولوجيا كذلك بالمقابل
انفتح قواتنا لاول مره قد تكون على الشريط
الحدود العراقي الايراني والعراقي التركي
من حيث حدود اقليم كردستان العراق مع
هاتين الدولتين وهذا بالتالي ما يؤسس الى
معنى اسياد المتكامله الذي تسعى اليه الان
حكومه السيد محمد الشيعه السوداني في
الوصول اليه واما ان نبقى حقيقه في ظل هذه
التحديات وفي ظل عدم وجود همم حل داخلي
الى هذه الازمه وكذلك عدم وجود تسويه
اقليميه من قبل الجانب الايراني ومن قبل
الجانب التركي طبعا سيبقى هذا تحدي للامن
الاقليمي وتستمر هذه المعضله التي مثلت
تمتد الى 40 سنه شكرا جزيلا لك من بغداد
المستشار الحكومي دكتور حسين علاوي تحياتي
اليك
وبينما يشكو شمال العراق من استمرار القصف
كان شمال سوريا يشيع قتل الغارات التركيه
12 قتيلا شيعوا الى مثواهم الاخير في ديرك
شمال شرق البلاد وصواعيدا بالانتقام من
نحو عشره الاف مشيع
المون لفقدان اثني عشر شخصا قتلتهم تركيا
في غارات جويه على الاكراد ليله السبت
المنصرم
اوه سيدنا
النبي
وذويهم مدنيون وعسكريون وصحفيون
قتلوا في ضربات التركيه الاخيره
ماذا فعلنا لهم لم يهاجمهم ولم نسرق
اموالهم لماذا يهاجموننا نحن على ارضنا
وفي وطننا لذلك لا نعرف اي تفسير لصمت
الدول الكبرى
[موسيقى]
تخطن شعبي رافقه تهديد جسد بالرد على
الغارات التركيه في الوقت المناسب وربما
تكون العمليتان العسكريتان في كل تركيا
وقرقميش بدايته بين حلم الاكراد في رؤيه
كردستانهم الموعوده وعمليات تركيا
المستمره لاجهاضه تبقى هذه البقعه من
الارض ساحه مفتوحه للقتل والقتال مع غياب
اي افقي لحلول سياسيه او عسكريه تنهي هذا
الصراع من مدينه ديرك شمال شرق سوريا
جماعه كاش العربيه
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا بعد الفاصل لقسوه
البرد احكامه اوكرانيا ترفض خساره الشبرن
من الارض لكنها لا تمانع في رحيل سكنيها
[موسيقى]
في الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه ضاعت بعثه
الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان كيف الى
التحقيق في فيديو اعدام الاسرى الروس كانت
الدفاع الروسيه اتهمت كيف بقتل 10 من
جنودها الاسرى وتوعدت بان لا تمر هذه
الجريمه من دون محاسبه معتبره ان الفيديو
المنشور لهذه المذبح الجماعيه بحق الاسرى
العزل يؤكد ما وصفته بطبيعه نظامك في
الوحشيه بقياده
اوكرانيا جرائم حرب من اي نوع واكدت ان
جنود الاوكرانيين كانوا في موقف الدفاع عن
النفس بعد ان تظاهر الجنوب الروس
بالاستسلام وفتحوا النار
تحررت خيصان واحتفل سكانها او ما تبقى
منهم بقوتهم المسلحه انتهت نشوه النصر
لتكشف عن حمل ثقيل من المشكلات القصف
الروسي والمتكرر على البنيه التحتيه خصوصا
محطه توليد الكهرباء والطاقه عدا عن
الدمار الواسع في المباني ترك المدينه
تعاني بشده حل الشتاء ثقيلا ونحن لا زلنا
في بدايته ليبدو ان الرهان الروسي على
الفصل القاسي بدا ياتي ثماره كمسكو تعمدت
تدمير هنا التحتيه للطاقه لتركيع الجاره
الغربيه خيرسون وميكو لايف المدينتان
الجنوبيتان الاكثر تضررا اليوم لا كهرباء
لا ماء عذب ولا معناه كافيه
وترحم السكان من قسوه الشتاء
والحلو ماساوي هكذا تفكر الحكومه
الاوكرانيه بجديه باجلاء سكان خرسان
وميكولايف نحو مناطق يستطيعون فيها البقاء
على قيد الحياه مع برد شتاء قد يصل الى 30
درجه تحت الصفر نائب رئيس الوزراء
الاوكرانيه
قالت انه في الايام القليله المقبله ستبدا
الحكومه في مساعده الاشخاص الذين يرغبون
في المغادره بالفعل لكنها شددت على ان
السكان سيتخذون قراراتهم الخاصه بشان
البقاء اضافه انه في الوقت الحالي لا حديث
عن اجلان قصري لكن وبما ان مدينه تيمكو
لايف واخرسون هدف متكرر للضربات الصاروخيه
الروسيه فقط طالب سكان المدينه بالانتقال
الى مناطقها اكثر امنا
[موسيقى]
وتزيد ماساه المدينه والمناطق المحيطه
بهما سقطت ما لا يقل عن اثنتي عشره قذيفه
في محطه زبو رجال الطاقه واتلفت عده اجهزه
في اكبر محطه نوويه في اوروبا تبادلت
الاتهامات بشان الضربات وكما ذكرنا بالامس
هنا اعتبر المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافايل جروسي ان ايا كان من
يقف وراء ذلك يجب ان يتوقف على الفور
وانما يحدث هو لاعب بالنار وفي حصيله
النادره افاد المدعي العام الاوكرانيا بان
نحو
437 طفلا يعتقد انهم من بين اكثر من
ثمانيه الاف و300 مدنيه قتلوا منذ بدء
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا اضافه انه في
ظل الندره المعلومات الموثوق بها من
المناطق التي تحتلها روسيا فمن المرجح ان
يكون العدد الحقيقي للقتلى اعلى بكثير
فضلا عن اكثر من احد عشر مصابا
ان المدنيين سجلوا في الساعات او ككل في
المجمل نتحدث عن احد عشر الف مصادق
بالعوده الى عدو سكان خرسان وميكولايف
الجديد الشتاء القارس يحاول الاهالي
التفادي مغادره بيوتهم باحثين عن ما توفره
الطبيعه لمواجهه البرد الحطب البديل
الطبيعيه للكهرباء لكن جلبه ليس بالامر
الهين ايضا حذرت سلطات الاوكرانيه
المواطنين من التوجه الى الغابات دون
استشاره الجيش لان القوات الروسيه ربما
تركت وراءها الغاما واسلاكا لكن قد تعثرهم
وقذف غير منفجره لكن مع ارتفاع اسعار
الحطب لم يعد امام الكثيرين خيار سوى
المخاطره
اذا لم يقتلهم لغم فقد يكون البرد هو
القاتل الجديد لكن ان كان الشتاء ليس في
صالح الاوكرانيين فلا يعني انه في صالح
الروس ايضا الذين سيواجهون الصعوبه بنقل
المعدات عبر الطين والثلج والجليد في سهول
الرياح هناك حيث يمكن ان تنخفض درجات
الحراره الى 30 درجه مئويه ناقص اي تحت
الصفر وفقا لمسؤولينا امريكيين فان قرار
الكراملين بالانسحاب من خرسان سند جزئيا
الى مخاوفه من ان الامدادات ستنقطع عن
الجنود مع حلول فصل الشتاء قبل اربعه ايام
كان الرئيس الاوكراني اكثر وضوحا في
محادثه له مع صحفيين قال اذا بقينا على
قيد الحياه هذا الشتاء اذا بقينا سنفعل
ذلك فستنتصر اوكرانيا بالتاكيد في هذه
الحرب
[موسيقى]
لكن لمكسيم ما تمشينكو رئيس شركه دي تي اي
وهي اكبر شركه كهرباء اوكرانيه خاصه له
راي الاخر
مفاجئ اذا طلب من المدنيين مغادره
اوكرانيا هذا الشتاء اذا استطعت وذلك
لمساعده البلاد في التعامل مع ازمه الطاقه
لجميع سكانها للبقاء في فصل الشتاء لان
الهجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه دمرت البنيه
التحتيه الرئيسه في حديث نهايه الاذاعه
البريطانيه اذا تمكنوا من العثور على مكان
البديل للاقامه لمده ثلاثه او اربعه اشهر
فسيكون ذلك مفيدا مفيدا جدا
[موسيقى]
نفى وزير الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان بشكل مقاطع
المملكه تناقش زياده انتاج النفط بمقدار
500000 برميل يوميا واكد الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان ان افضل انتاج الحلي
بمقدار من يوميا مستمر حتى نهايه عام 20
23 وقال وزير الطاقه السعوديه له من
المعروف
لا تبحث اي قرارات قبل اجتماعاتها واشار
الى الاستعداد للتدخل الاجراءات اخرى لخفض
الانتاج للموازنه بين العرض والطلب عند
الحجر
[موسيقى]
نانسي اعلنت عدم سعيها مجددا لقياده الحزب
الديمقراطيه
بالكونجرس الامريكي ما فتح الباب امام
الطامحين لخلافتها رئيسه مجلس النواب
الحاليه تنتهي ولايتها بحلول يناير المقبل
ويبدا بعدها الحزب في مرحله اعاده رسم
مسار الجديد الديمقراطيين لاول مره منذ
عقود المسار الجديد سيبدا مع تراجع اول
ثلاث قيادات برلمانيه نانسي
بعدها نتحدث عن الثاني
عند شخصيات اعلنت عن ترشحها للمناصب
القياديه منهم حكيم جافريز اذا نتحدث عن
حكيم جافريز وكذلك ايضا عن
كلارك
هم الذين عبروا عن سعيهم بشغل المناصب
القياديه مع رحيل الحرس القديم
المرشحون الثلاثه يتميزون بعمر اصغر من
القيادات الحاليه فهم اقل من 60 عاما من
العمر ايضا التنوع العرقي والجنسي قد يمثل
دعما لهم
حكيم جافريز مرشح لان يكون اول شخص من
اصول افريقيه في منصب قيادي بالحزبين في
اي من مجلسي الكونجرس وايضا بوجود كافرين
كلارك سيضمن الحزب وجود سيده في قيادته
اما الطرف الثالث
سيكون ثاني مشرع من اصل لاتيني يتراس
المؤتمر الحزبي اذا تم انتخابه هذا الشهر
واشنطن التقط باكثر من 20 من اعضاء
الكونجرس عند الحزب الديمقراطي وعبره عن
تفائلهم بشان الجيل الجديد من القاده
المتوقع ان يتولى زمام الامور
عذرا لكن ظلال نانسي فيلوسي ستبقى فوق
القياده الجديده فبحسب الصحيفه يدرك
الديمقراطيون في مجلس النواب باغلبيه
ساحقه انه لا يوجد زعيم واحد في الجيل
الجديد يمكن ان يكون بنفس قوه بنفس قدرتها
على تحقيق نتائج تشريعيه من خلال اقناع
الاعضاء من خلال دفعهم في الاتجاه المطلوب
بدون القبضه المشدده لقياده بيلوسي يتخوف
الحزب من ان يخلق الواقع الجديد سيناريو
لا يمكن فيه لاحد التحكم في مطالب الاعضاء
احد اعضاء كونغرس الذين تحدثوا الى واشنطن
بوست شريطه عدم الكشف عن نسمه قال انه لم
يعد النواب في حاله خوف من رئيس مجلس
النواب فربما تخرج الامور عن السيطره هنا
كانت اهميه
ويرى العديد من الديمقراطيين ان التغيير
مخاطره ولكن تستحق المجازه
لسانههم مما وصفه بالحكم من اعلى الى اسفل
وهم يبحثون عن قاده جدد ينخرطون في كثير
من الاحيان مع الاجنحه المختلفه للحزب في
الكونجرس الثلاثي القيادي المرتقب في
الكونجرس المقبل جافيريز وكلارك واجيلار
قضى الكثير من الوقت خلال الفتره الماضيه
في التقويه العلاقات مع اعضاء الحزب
واكدوا انهم سيعتمدون على نقاط القوه
لبعضهم البعض لتقريب الجامع وجوهات النظر
على طاوله الحوار الداخليه في الحزب وفي
حين يوجد حماس كبير للمسار الجديد للحزب
عبر العديد من الاعضاء الديمقراطيين عن
سعادتهم لسماع ان الحرس القديم سيظل
موجوده في الفتره المقبله للاخذ بهذه
القياده الجديده على امل العوده بعد عامين
لاستعاده السيطره على مجلس النواب
ايقونات
فقدان الاشخاص او تنحي الاشخاص هل يمكن ان
يؤدي الى كل هذا التخوف
ادي ايوب تسمعني انت معنا على الهواء
طيب واضح
المستشار الديمقراطي عبر زوم من واشنطن قد
نعود اليك بعد قليل لمتابعه هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
اعرضت شركه الاتصالات الفرنسيه ارقام عن
قلقها من عواقب الاقالات في تويتر على
المستخدمين وطالبه اداره المنصه بالالتزام
بمكافحه خطاب الكراهيه والتلاعب يبدو ان
ملك المنصه الجديده الملياردير الامريكيه
ايلون ماسك لا يكف عن اطلاق تغريداته
المثيره للجدل اخرها تغريده تتعلق باعاده
حساب المنظر الامريكي وصاحب نظريات
المؤامره
انزالوا التسريحات او عاصفه الاستقالات لا
فرق كلاهما ينذر بكارثه في تويتر فالدخول
من باب الشركه حتما ليس كخروجه
عدو هجران تويتر لم تقتصر على افراد
بعينهم بل ان شركات باسرها حولت مسارتها
الى منصه اخرى بسبب ترنح التطبيق على ايدي
الملياردير الامريكي الى ماسك نصف
الموظفين الى النصف ثم قال لبقيتهم اما ان
تعملوا بتسال غير مشروط والا فرحلوا وفعلا
غادروا بلا ان ينظروا وراءهم ليتركوا
الطائره الازرق لاجنحه تعتصر الف موظف ما
زالوا صامدين رغم انهم قد يغيرون ارائهم
لاحقا فالافلاس وارد في ظل تراجع
الاعلانات التي تمثل 90% من دخل الشركه
امام ماسك الذي يسر على ان عصفوره حي يرزق
ولقفص سيذبح نشاطه يمطر المستخدمين بغزاره
تغريداته وبين الحين والاخر يبدو انه
يضمنها شيئا من حياته الخاصه
اخرها حول امكانيه اعاده حساب المنظر
الامريكي وصاحبي نظريات المؤامره اليكس
جونز بشان مذبحه وقعت في مدرسه عام 2012
وراحه ضيتها 28 طفلا لياتي الجواب صارما
ومستذكرا به مراره فقد ابنه الذي لم
يتجاوز ال 10 اسابيع هذا الغني المصنف
كاحد اثرياء العالم سبق وان صرح ايضا بانه
مشرد بلا منزل يقويه وحياته ليست مطرفه
كما يخير للبعض وبغض النظر الى ان العوده
الى احضان تويتر لم تكن برفع الحظر عن
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب فحسب
وانما على مغني الراب الشهير كنيست الذي
سبق والتهم بمعادته الساميه حينما ارتدي
قميصا كتب عليه حياه البيض مهمه
ليبدو ماسك بشكل او باخر متضامنا معه
ولمن لا يعرف فان الماسك الذي ولد في 28
يونيو عام
1971 في بريتوريا امه كنديه وابوه من جنوب
افريقيا ذو اصول هولنديه وبريطانيه اي انه
ثلاثي الجنسيه اخرها حصوله على الامريكيه
قبل 20 سنه انا منه ترعرعت على حب القراءه
وكان شغوفا باجهزه الحاسوب وتطوير
البرمجيات
لكنه مصاب بمتلازمه احد اضطرابات الطيف
التوحد اسبرجر التي وصفها خبراء الصحه
بانها قد تكون النقطه قوه في انجازات
وابتكارته ماسك الذي ينوي ان يحلق مع
طائره الازرق بنسخه محدثه يقول فيها وداعا
لتويتر القديم
اسراء الصغير العربيه
اهلا بك معنا حسين ما يعني اخر ما نسمع من
ردود افعال من من تتحدث اليهم من مصادرك
من المسؤولين ربما من موظفين حاليا او
سابقين خاصه مع الهجمه الكبرى من عده جهات
اخرها فرنسيه ايضا من المنظمه الاتصالات
الفرنسي يدعو تويتر للحفاظ على السياسه
واضحه ضد الكراهيه والعنف
تحيه لك طاهر انا الان موجود امام مبنى
تويتر في الحقيقه منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى
ننتظر ان نرى موظفا يدخل موظف يخرج لانه
اليوم الاثنين هو اليوم الذي سيعود به
الموظفون الى المبنى الرئيسي هنا في سان
فرانسيسكو كما بات معروفا ولكن حتى الان
لم نشاهد احد تحولنا الدخول اقتراب في
ساعات الصباح الاولى من المبنى الرئيسي
وحلاوه الدخول الى البوابه الرئيسيه
لتويتر في الداخل كما تشاهدون همم عندما
راوا عارفوا اننا صحفيين رفضوا التحدث
الينا وطالبون بالابتعاد الوقوف عند
الشارع همم تحدث الى بعض همم
الموظفين الموظفين همم الاستقبال قالوا لي
انه ربما على الساعه همم الساعه الثانيه
عشر بتوقيت سان فرانسيسكو هنا قد يكون
هناك اجتماع ولكن لا ليسوا متاكدين سالتهم
كيف نتاكد كيف نتواصل معهم ليست لدينا
معلومات لكن طلبه منها التجهيز وبالفعل
اغلاق بعد الابواب ايه الداخليه لهذا
الباب الرئيسي سنقترب منه الان نحاول
اقتراب منه همم كما تشاهد طاهر هناك اليوم
هناك حضور اعلامي لعدد من هذه القنوات
التلفزيونيه هناك توقع بان يكون همم اعلان
شيء كما ذكرت الصحف الامريكيه بان يكون
اعلان همم فصل او اقاله عدد من الموظفين
لاسيما موظفين المبيعات والتسويق الاعلامي
همم هذا هو المبلغ الرئيسي هنا نتحدث عن
مبنيين ال- ال- المدخل هناك همم سحاول
اقتراب اكثر
ولكن لا يسمح لنا اعلاميين الدخول يقولون
هذا
ممتلكات خاصه يسمح للشخص ان يقتل عادي
ولكن لا يكون لديه كاميرا همم تحدثت انا
قمت بجوله في المحلات التجاريه هنا
والمقاهي سالت العاملين بهذه المقاهي قلت
لهم هل تميزون اشخاص كانوا يعملون في
التويتر ياتون اليكم والان لم يعدوا قالوا
لنا بالفعل هذا لاحظنا من بعد ان استحوذ
ايله الماس على شركه تويوتا هناك العديد
من من الاشخاص الذين كانوا يرونهم ياتون
اليهم يعرفون انهم يعملون في تويتر الان
لم يعد يرهم قالوا لي ربما لانهم تريدوا
لانهم استقاله هذا يعني من التاثيرات همم
الفصل تاثيرات الاقاله على المنطقه
المجاوره هنا والعاملين بها لاحظوا غياب
الكثير فهم اشاروا لي انهم عنده كرونه همم
كان هناك عمل همم عن بعد من ولكن الان هذا
ازداد اكثر بالنسبه لمن كانوا ياتون
ويداويمون في هذا المبنى المبنى الرئيسي
لتويتر في سان فرانسيسكو طاهر همم يعني
احاول ان همم انتظر مع كل من ينتظر ما
الذي سيقوله ايلان ماسك من جديد فيما
يتعلق بقراراته همم الاخيره ولكن عموما
همم اريد ان اعرف من كيف تتفاعل هذه
القضيه عند همم الناس في الولايات المتحده
الى اي مدى هم اهتمون بما يحصل في تويتر
عند السلطات المعنيه بشكل مباشر عند
الاعلام ايضا الامريكي كيف تتفاعل هذه
القضيه
طبعا هذه القضيه تجد تفاعلا كبيرا لدى
مختلف الشرائح في الحقيقه نحن نتحدث عن
اعداد كبيره من الموظفين سيتم تسريحهم او
انهم استقالوا من تلقائي انفسهم رفضا
للقوانين التي او الشروط التي يفردها لهم
ماسك والتي بالمناسبه حذر سابقا مديرون
تنفيذيون في المؤسسه ماس من ان خطته
لتصريح الموظفين لطرد الموظفين قد تنتهي
قوانين العمل
رسميا نحن نعلم انه في الكونجرس الان هناك
سبعه همم اعضاء في مجلس الشيوخ طلبوا من
الهيئه التجاريه الفدائيه التحقيق فيما
اذا كان همم تويتر همم اخترق خصوصيه
المستخدمين همم ام لا رسميا هناك طبعا
تفاعل معه خاصه همم فيما يتعلق بالقمريس
في مجلس الشيوخ ومجلس النواب ولا نستبعد
في الحقيقه بشان موضوع الخصوصيه ان ان همم
او همم مشاهد جلسات استماع كما حصل مع
تويتر وعفوا مع فيسبوك وانستغرام همم ردود
الفعل طبعا هناك همم الكثير مما يقولون
بانهم مع همم هم لديهم حسابات في تويتر
منذ 10 10 سنوات او اكثر هو بالنسبه لها
هو منصه للتعبير عن الراي الان ااه لهم
ماسك همم
يتهمونه بانه بدا يسمح بخطاب الكراهيه
يتخوفون من عوده ترامب يقولون ان ترامب
الان سيكون لديه مساحه واسعه ان يبث
افكاره التي يبصها وينشرها عبر ااه
رغم ان ترامب حتى الان همم نفع انه سيعود
الى تويتر
هنا في الولايات المتحده تتخوف من ذلك
وتطالب الشركات الكبرى التي تعلن في
التربيه ان تتوقف عن الاعلام تويتر اذا لم
يتوقف همم عن همم
السماح خطاب الكراهيه رغم ان لهم مصر في
الحقيقه همم طاهر هو اعلن انه لن يسمح بخط
كره هي وقال بانه همم اي تغريده همم تحث
على على الكراهيه لن يتم الترويج لها
ولكنه في المقابل قال انه لن يحذفها لن
يحدثها ستبقى موجوده ولكن لن يتم الترويج
لها هو يؤكد على انه لا يريد خطاب القراءه
وما يريد ان يفعله ان يكون هناك حريه
للتعبير اوسع همم وهذا لهذا السبب هو
اعاده تفعيل حساب همم دونالد ترامب حسابات
عدد من الاشخاص الذين كانوا قد حضروا
سابقا سنكفي معك بهذا القدر الان ولكن لنا
عوده لاحقه اليك لنرصد معك محيط شركه
تويتر اذا في سان فرانسيسكو مع ترقب
الاعلانات الجديده الكثيره في الواقع الى
الماسك هذه الايام شكرا جزيلا لك حسين
الطاوض مراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
وسفير الامريكي في اليمن يعرب عن قلقه من
احتمال تجدد التصعيد في البلاد نعود الى
شان الامريكي وتجديد الدماء في داخل الحزب
الديمقراطي في الكونغرس على وجه التحديد
معنا من واشنطن ايوب المستشار الديمقراطي
اهلا بك معنا ارجو انك تسمعني الان استاذ
اديكون سالتك هل المشكله في غياب النهج
لكي نصبح عند واقع ااه يعني فيه الكثير من
الهواجس والقلق عند المحاذبين عندما تغيب
شخصيات قياديه مثل بيروسي
حوادث حوادث
مبكرا
لنقوم بهذا الافتراض فلا يمكننا ان نشدد
على مدى اهميه نادي بيلوسي كزعاعيما
للمجلس النواب والان لابد لنا ان نقول
بانها المراه الاولى التي قامت بالاحتفاظ
بهذا المنصب منذ
وجودي هذا الحزب على تاريخه لدينا نائبه
للرئيس ايضا وكذلك كانت قد
اعتركت في السياسه بصوره كبيره وتمتلك
مهارات وباء ولديها باع طويل في التعاطي
مع كائنات مختلفه ومع اشخاص مختلفه لذا
اعتقدوا بانه ما
زال من المبكر ان نقوم باجراء التقييمن
اذا ما كان هناك هذا الفراغ لانه تذكر ان
الجمهوريين سوف يقومون بالحصول على هذا
همم على مجلس النواب عندما يكون مكان فيه
هو الزعيم الذي الخاص بمجموعتين لذا قد
تكون هناك مناوره بين الطرفين حتى اللحظه
لمعرفه ما الذي يحصل في الكونغرس الجديد
الذي سوف يبدا بعد شهرين من هي الشخصيات
القادره باعتقادك على ان تتسلم زمام
الامور او على الاقل ان تبدا في همم مسار
قياديا واضح ان كان من خلال شخصيتها او من
خلال الدعم الذي تلقاه
سعود سعود حكيم جعفر
والاجتماعات سوف تعقدوا في الاسبوع القادم
لكن النتيجه مؤكده فهو سوف يكون زعيم
الحزب الديمقراطي في الكونغرس وهي وهو
اعلى منصب قد يكون موجود في الحزب لكن لا
يخفى عليكم ايضا بان هناك مستشارين مثل
امثال بانه هناك مشكله في المراسله
المراسلات التي تجمعنا قد اثبت الانتخابات
النصفيه ان رسائل بين الحزب الديمقراطي قد
تكون بدايه مغزى للشعب وهذا عرفناه قبل
يومين من عقد الانتخابات فكان الكل يتوقع
بالموجه الحمراء وان الجمهوريه سوف سيطرون
على
المجلس النواب مجلس الشيوخ بعشرات المقاعد
لكن الامر لم يحدث ذلك
باربعه المقاعد
حتى انه سؤال مشروع يجب طرحه من الذي سوف
يكون وجه القياده الجديد وما هي المقاربه
الجديده القد اجاب الشعب على هذا السؤال
في الانتخابات النصفيه من خلال وجود اقليه
اقل من الجمهور حتى في وجه كل ما تحدث عنه
الجمهوريون في كافه القضايا المتعلقه سواء
تمطر على برنامجكم او في اماكن اخرى شكرا
لوجودك معنا في هذه الليله عبر الزومبا
واشنطن ادي ايوب المستشار الديمقراطيه
تحياتي اليك
ونحن بكونا معكم لنتابع ايضا بعد الفاصل
ولكن نشير الى الخبر العاجل وزير الطاقه
الاماراتيه في اي مناقشات مع اعضاء اوبك
بلس بشان قرار خفض الانتاج ساري حتى
20-320 متظاهرون في الفلبين يناشدون
رئيسهم لا تبتلع طعم كما لاهاريس
[موسيقى]
لماذا تغلقون الطريق يردون نحن نناشطون
مناخ مصالحنا تتعطل لدينا اعمال وهناك
متعبون ومرضى في السيارات لماذا تفعلون
ذلك يكررون لاننا نعشق هذا الطفل توتر
وربما غيره كثيرون ايضا في السيارات لماذا
لا ترفقون بهم يعلنون نحن نناشطه مناخ اذا
اهتموا بالمناخ ودعوا السيارات تتحرك او
اذا اهتموا بالمناخ فقط ودعوا السيارات
تتحرك بدلا من حرقي وقودها وتلوث الهواء
بلا طائر يجيبون نحن نعرف ماذا نفعل فنحن
راشطون مناخ في مشهد كهذا لا تفهم حقيقه
ما الذي يفيد المناخ من افعال نشيطه
المناخ احيانا
فيديو اليوم كر وفر بين الامن الفلبيني
والمحتاجين على زياره كما لهاريس نائبه
الرئيس الامريكي للبلاد يؤمن هؤلاء باللا
شيء في بلادهم يستحقوا زياره اكثر من
قربها من الصين ولا يريدون ان يكون جزءا
من هذه اللعبه بالطبع ستنفي هارس ايا نيه
سيئه وراء زيارتها التي ستشمل جزر بلا وان
على حافه بحر الصين الجنوبيه وهذه الجزيره
بالذات تمثل حجر عثره في مساعي بكين
للسيطره البحريه الواسعه يدرك المحتاجون
كل هذا ولذا يؤكدونا على رئيسهم لا تبتلع
الطعمه
هكذا نكون قد وصلنا الى ختامي ملفات
العربيه 360